p'tain voici donc tous les bistrots ce
professeur à sao paulo vous faites très
vite de l'ethnologie ou s'apprend
consomme en quelle année en sommes au
début 35
savez j'étais complètement autodidacte
ne lui ai jamais suivi un cours
d'ethnologie en france
d'ailleurs il n'existait pas encore de
chair d'ethnologie dans les universités
françaises mais au moins on pouvait
enfin il y avait des enseignements un
peu par un universitaire et donc je
savais rien du tout
alors j'ai commencé
j'avais des étudiants bien sûr de moi
commencer à faire de la technologie dans
la ville de me dire que
la ville m'a toujours passionné comme
objet d'étude parce que ça s'est
constitué à travers les années en fait
chez nous à travers les siècles les
millénaires en amérique du sud plus
récemment mais par une quantité de
petites décisions individuelles sans
aucun plan d'ensemble et avec très peu
et puis peu l'accumulation de ces choix
individuel fait un être qui a une
existence une réalité organique et donc
nous avons commencé à travailler dans
san paolo et je demandais que je me
rappelle à mes étudiants
comme sujet de mémoire de faire une
monographie de la rue dans lequel il
habitait chose de gens et puis dès qu'il
y avait un peu de vacances
quelques jours quelques semaines je
filais dans l'intérieur d'abord pas
extrêmement loin mais dans le sud du
brésil enfin jours de voyage on peut
déjà trouver des petits groupements
indien s'est abîmé qui vivent comme des
paysans brésiliens merpins qui sont tout
de même des indiens et j'ai décidé que
mes premières grandes vacances au lieu
de rentrer en france comme faisais mes
camarades bien je filerai chez les
alliés dans l'intérieur c'est ce que
j'ai fait
première la deuxième année et puis
ensuite dont j'ai rapporté des
collections ethnographiques à paris
elles ont été exposées par le musée de
l'homme on m'a accepté comme un
ethnologue de plein droit et j'ai pu
obtenir des crédits pour faire une
mission d'une année alors de l'intérieur
tient dur et comme je le rappelais toute
allure jusqu'à la veille de la guerre